hey guys happy tech tuesday this is
actually a review that i meant to do
around christmas time because these are
sort of christmasy type lights but
obviously i didn't do it but i've still
got the lights and i wanted to show them
to you and i wanted to see what you guys
think
these are called lumen play app enabled
lights and there's also a little
something up here that says bluetooth so
i'm excited to see if this is actually
bluetooth controlled if it uses wi-fi
and we're going to find out right here
and you're going to watch me figure it
out this is the starter pack which has
the controller in it and this is the
extender string so you can extend the
starter pack into a few more lights 12
feet and another 12 feet
let's open where's my knife
we've got just a little baby knife here
today for opening so if you're new here
you probably haven't seen me talk about
it yet but i'm a huge fan of the hue
light bulbs i have them all around my
house and those are wi-fi enabled and
they're just a single little bulb that
you can pop into your already existing
light fixtures it's all connected on
wi-fi you can use an app you can change
the colors on your computer
i hope i didn't plan on taking this back
you better not suck or i'm going to be
real pissed
i'm not sure if you guys ever heard of
the company missed it but they just came
out with a light bulb also that connects
to wi-fi misfit is also a company that
creates fitness trackers and i'm a huge
fan of those so i'm excited to check out
the stuff that they're working on in the
lighting space so as you will see
as we open this box up these are really
big these look like the christmas lights
that my parents had when i was first
born i was a fetus and these are like
these are fetus lights this is what i
remember christmas lights look like when
i was a child this is really festive i'm
i the holiday season is over i really
missed the boat ship has sailed it's
taken off without me i'm at the shore
i'm sitting there at the dock crying
with my christmas lights i always love
how all the beauty gurus have really
cute little twinkle lights behind them
i'm gonna have behind me a christmas
freaking parade this is real thick have
a holly jolly christmas first
impressions are like what real thick
let's just say there's something missing
okay so looks like you just stick you in
here for indoor and outdoor use oh that
just really that just turned the page in
my book i'm gonna plug this in
um
okay
so it says plug in your lights download
the free lumen app and have fun that's
like three simple steps it's so fluffy
so we're doing a firmware update
understood
so we're updating now let it go
let it go guys i still haven't seen
frozen yet this is great it says right
here that you can hang it for any
occasion weddings christmas fireworks
birthdays wine drinking party football
horse racing barbecue i don't want you
to miss out on anything okay holy moly i
have a christmas tree okay now we've got
this figured out we can just change
colors like this is it this is so
freaking cool i can't wait to have a
party i have to have a party now i'm
gonna need to have a party look at this
so you just you just pick
you can oh this is freaking great
okay i'm gonna change my colors
you just scroll through
and you can just pick the colors and it
changes the colors what the what the i
freaking love
everything a single fade a nice single
fade
okay let's go back we're going to change
the colors again this looks nice a nice
festive something so these are the lumen
lumen play initial thought is holy crap
this was so easy to set up a lot of
these other wi-fi enabled lights it is a
little bit more of a process because you
have to connect a little mini router to
your actual router and then you have to
do a little bit of setup there's
absolutely
zero
zero setup i mean i plugged them in
connected
my phone to bluetooth downloaded the app
and that was essentially it and here we
are having a party i'm so
turnt up right now that that's my review
i'm i'm actually going to keep the
extenders too i'm going to have a wine
and horse racing party and i'm going to
use these lights see you guys later
happy tech tuesday